الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اذا قرر الترشح
لولايه ثانيه فمن المرجح ان تقف سمعه نجله
عقبه امام تحقيق طموحه بالمقعد الرئاسي
مجددا هنتر بايدن نجل الرئيس ما زال يثير
الجدل الذي اشتد هذا الاسبوع خاصه بعد ان
اصدر رئيس الرقابه في مجلس النواب جيمس
كومر امر استدعاء الى بنك امريكا للحصول
على سجلات مصرفيه متعلقه بهنتر وشركائه
التجاريين
رئيس الرقابه البرلمانيه وصف لابن الاصغر
للرئيس بالفاسد متهما اياه بتهديد الامن
القومي الامريكي عبر ابرامه صفقات سريه مع
الصين وروسيا واوكرانيا
السجلات الماليه محل التحقيق تعود ل 14
عاما مضت وتشمل صفقات تجاريه اجنبيه ما
سيسمح للمحققين بالكشف عن اي انشطه مشبوهه
لعائله بايدن لا سيما تلك التي يقول
الجمهوريون ان الرئيس نفسه قد استفاد منها
البيت الابيض وصف التحقيق الجاري في تلك
القضيه بانه يحمل دوافع سياسيه نافيا في
السابق تورط بايدن في اي من الصفقات
الخارجيه لابنه هانتر المتهم ايضا بالتهرب
الضريبي وكذلك تعاطي المخدرات عام 2018
الامر الذي لن ينجو منه ايضا والده الرئيس
الامريكي خاصه فيما يتعلق بحظوظه لفتره
رئاسيه قادمه
محللون راوا انه في حال اثبت التحقيق تلك
التهم بحق هنتر بايدن ستوقع عليه عقوبه
تشمل الغرامه الماليه والسجن لمده تصل الى
19 عاما